[Music]
gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most
elite team of firefighters in the world
we must be in our very best what I say
we do no go for extraction
so we can get you back to your parents
I'm legally bound to take Arius that's
why I'm gonna do an intern you're gonna
feel BD it's a week into our job when
you do this when you go like oh like
that it's not helpful ghostin Anakin's
under my watch we buy your man can't
turn my neck what needs to happen this
second is you got to watch your tone
little sister or what masher is coming
to rock you were what just happened I
think the baby just broke it dog suit
daddy
I get distracted I can't do this job
effectively don't you remember what it's
like to be a kid did we kill you
well now it's a party
what kind of firefighters are you I know
you don't see it but he has a sweet side
what a rush
boom-boom-boom-boom
look at me
don't do it or I'm gonna legally bound
to curious that's what learn to intern
you're gonna touch the attitude and be
obedient so we can do our job fighting
fires why does it have to be fighting
the buyers kind of just be containing it
or resolving it oh my gosh for crying
out loud I can no longer hold my tongue
so what needs to happen right now like
literally this second is you got to
watch your tone little sister or what or
what okay I'm oh I know what
[Music]
[Music]
good God gave me what what just happened
I think the baby broke your dog her
name's masher
her name is mash
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
put that down no shenanigans on my watch
yeah no monkeyshines tomfoolery or high
jinks you finished long as there's not a
hint of malarkey oh now if I didn't know
any better I would say that that was
sarcasm
so why don't we just take it down a
notch sister okay maybe a little
gratitude would be helpful
sorry bud we just don't speak old Z
times oh my gosh oh my god she's not
stopping no I believe that used to make
the most delicious jalapeno chocolate
cake you ever had the secret ingredient
in chocolate sounds weird but when you
taste it oh it's so always they never
touch your face with but now my eyes
burning my eyes burning and my lips are
on fire
[Music]
[Music]
kill you
[Music]
[Music]